you want to make money from your passion
that passion needs to be able to add
value to someone else how do you figure
this out the first way you can go about
it is you can think about who is the
person or the community or the group of
people that you ideally want to add
value to let's say for example I have a
passion for playing the guitar if I
think about who I can add value to I
could add value to an audience because
they might pay me to hear me perform my
guitar I could add value to kids who
want to learn the guitar adults who
might want to learn the guitar people
who run local community groups at my
local church or youth camps or
volunteering programs because they might
want to hire me as a performer for one
of their parties restaurant owners who
might want background music it's like
just taking this thing that I'm
passionate about and instead of asking a
question how do I make money from
playing the guitar it's like who are the
potential people I can add value to
because ultimately the only way you make
money is by providing value and usually
providing value means solving a specific
problem for someone else